herzlich willkommen beim sommer auf
youtube wir gehen raus nicht nur mit dem
frage videos sondern auch mit unseren
gästen und unser nächster gast ist
niemand geringeres als alexy beck sieht
die stimme auf youtube er wird ja gerne
von dem ein oder anderen youtube kanal
als ob sprecher gebucht und er kann auch
singen und ist dazu noch unglaublich
kreativ zum beispiel in seinen
erklärvideos also es gibt eine menge zu
fragen hoffentlich auch von euch und
zwar als kommentare unter diesem video
und als video antworten dafür einfach
ins kommentarfeld klicken dann gibt es
dann neben den link den link um eine
video antwort hochzuladen und die sollte
möglichst einfallsreich sein und ihr
solltet vorher den info text gelesen
haben und ansonsten kann nichts mehr
schiefgehen alexei beck sie und ich
freuen uns auf eure zahlreichen fragen
und ansonsten bis dann